das ist für mich immer noch so eine
sache da denke ich mir das war schon vor
drei jahren war das mal in der zone aber
kommt leute ganz ehrlich das kann man
doch nicht machen
hey leute was geht ab märz willkommen
beim neuen video darf ich vorstellen
mein neuer style
das ist meine neue rose heißt oder
kleiner witz am rande
wir haben ja mottowoche also dieses wo
man sich so verkleidet in der schule und
ich war heute so was voll cool oder also
ich find die hose eigentlich richtig
geil ich hätte niemals gedacht dass ich
das danach auch noch an behalte weil
dies so bequem und da kann man auch
direkt von die überleitung finden zum
heutigen video und zwar geht es heute um
die hässlichsten klamotten die welt je
gesehen hat und die würde ich mir jetzt
mal angucken ich habe mir da so ein paar
rausgesucht und die sind echt ultra
hässlich also meiner meinung nach sind
die ultra hässlich ich will jetzt auch
neben wird angreifen das trägt oder so
schild euer leben nicht dass hier wieder
kommen du bist voll scheiße keine ahnung
wie das wort heißt fällt mir gar nicht
ein auf jeden fall die hässlichsten
klamotten
ich will gar nicht lange lagern meine
hose findet ihr könnt ja meine
kommentare schreiben wie findet ihr
diese hose die ist auch eigentlich
richtig weiß oder ich würde sagen wir
fangen hier habe ich mir so direkt
gedacht sowie so bitte ich mein was ist
da bitte so die absicht dieses
modeherstellers bzw
dieses models weil man kann doch
niemanden wirklich dazu überreden sich
so was zu kaufen bei diesen ganzen
fashion weeks und so da geht es also
darum so was cooles zu zeigen was die
leute auch kaufen
aber es kommt doch keiner das könnt ihr
mir doch nicht erzählen dass sie einfach
aus wie eine nette frau die nur haut hat
und keine und so was ihr wisst schon und
was wir direkt aufgefallen ist das jetzt
ja so eng da kann man ja ungefähr auf
hüfthöhe noch etwas schnee einfach nein
egal wir machen weiter hiermit was ist
das warum so die oberteile sind doch
alle voll cool außer dass ganz rechts
der rechts sieht irgendwie so aus wie so
ein schwuler gärtner darf ich das jetzt
sagen oder nicht ich habe nichts gegen
schwule aber irgendwie also das rechte
outfit ist schon mal der höhepunkt das
ist einfach
und das kann man nicht tragen wenn so
eine raus geht der wird doch direkt
verprügelt von anderen leuten weil er so
scheiße aussieht der mitte finde ich der
ist doch cool so hallt das t shirt an
sich völlig mega aber dieser rock da
warum trägt bei eindruck warum kriegt
man als mann eindruck ich verstehe es
nicht er sieht aus wie und das ganz
links ist bis zur hüfte hin auch voll
okay aber dann kommt auch wieder so ein
scheiß und was haben die bitte für
schuhe an diese sind das sandalen oder
manche leute da denke ich mir auch so
klar ist mal wieder was neues zu machen
aber mit so was wie kommt man darauf so
was das ist dass leute tragen ich
verstehe dich ich würde so etwas niemals
in meinem ganzen leben anziehen was das
sieht aus das ist auch wer zum beispiel
für diese fashion weeks oder so wo ich
mir denke was bringen diese sachen weil
man die kann man doch nicht anziehen man
die sieht aus wie ein bonbon sowie
sollen keine ahnung orangen bonbon was
lag einst hier hoch mit schleife könnte
aufmachen ok solche sachen trägt man
dann auch irgendwelchen komischen
abschluss festen oder bellen oder sowas
bällen nicht fußball so halt so ihr
wisst schon es war jetzt nicht so lustig
ich weiß aber selbst dafür sieht doch
mit abstand das komisch sind bonbon okay
war also so wenn die halt wirklich auf
dem opernball oder abi ball oder
sonstwas bonbons verteilen würde dann
könnte man sich so anziehen sonst aber
nicht oder nicht das ist für mich immer
noch so eine sache da wenn ich mir das
war ja schon vor drei jahren war das mal
in dieser zone aber kommen leute ganz
ehrlich das kann man doch nicht machen
längst sind für frauen bestimmen hot
pants sind für frauen bestimmt keine
ahnung was noch fünf frauen bestimmtes
hohe schuhe also sind auch für frauen
bestimmt für männer ist vielleicht nicht
unbedingt alles bestimmt bald
jogginghosen können ja auch frauen
tragen caps können auch frauen tragen
männer dienste auf frauen
dass er nicht also männer dies wenn dann
schon für männer bestimmt aber für mich
gehören jetzt auch einfach nur so zu
frau ich meine man kann doch keine
leggins tragen dass die einfach durchs
haus oder das sieht nur männlich aus das
sieht einfach zu hause und auch noch mit
diesen schuhen was ist das bitte dar als
für mich dann wirklich irgendwo auf ich
mein so ich würde niemals auf die idee
kommen mir eine leggins zu bestellen das
heißt ja meckerns für für männer die
heißen megans übrigens oder soll ich mir
meine mails bestellen leute
wenn dieses video 15.000 like street
bestätigt mir eine mail ins heft das
habe ich gesagt nein das macht spaß
verstand seine hässliche hosen axway
track trace leute das war's mit dem
video wien zurück gefallen hat und ich
mir meine mails bestellen sollte dann ja
sagt bescheid oder last heute nacht
gerade man sonst würde ich sagen wir
sehen uns am sonntag um 18 uhr das
nächste video
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen tag
instagram snapper als eingeblendet hier
oben links gelehrt wie ich das gerade
gesagt wie sein lehrer in der jungen
linken zweiter mit meinem letzten video
zeigt dass auf jeden fall hier oben
irgendwo ab und wir sehen uns dann haben
sondern wie schon gesagt bereit